[Music]
we're tired
[Applause]
we're tired of our cries and anguish not
being heard me what community looks like
we're tired of our pain being overlooked
we're tired of keeping our heads down or
not making any trouble
when our elders are being assaulted
stabbed and killed
wouldn't you be the hate field attacks
on asian americans are disturbing
but why are we surprised for many of us
as asian americans in this country
we know what it feels like to be told we
don't belong
that we're perpetually foreigners and
even though others try to minimize us to
one entity
we represent so many different cultures
so many different backgrounds
so many different stories what do you
think happens next in a society
where we've normalized xenophobia at the
highest levels
you need to leave well you need you do
not talk about just like that
you need to leave asian pieces
people assign blame to those who don't
deserve it people are emboldened to
vandalize asian-owned businesses
people feel like it's okay to yell at
you in public based on your race
normalizing hate speech stokes the
flames of racism and leads to an 84 year
old thai grandfather
lying helpless on the streets of san
francisco left to die after being
attacked
84 years old the next week
a 64 year old grandmother assaulted in
san jose and a filipino-american man
slashed across the face in new york city
we're tired of this hateful violence
we're tired of talking about it
but we're not done speaking out far from
it listen to your aapi brothers and
sisters
we must learn to love one another to
hear one another's anguish and actually
care don't overlook the pain those
around you are experiencing on a daily
basis
reach out to offer your support to
educate others
and let's put an end to this violence
and hate together